[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport le
magazine est consacré comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département à ces parties a pour le
sommaire football montre le bretonneux
et la sensation hesdinois de ce
troisième tour de coupe de france ce
dimanche les unit mantin se sont imposés
aux tirs au but face à choisy le roi
mythique qu'est boullier pourtant trois
divisions au-dessus les détails dans ce
magazine course insolite le parc
zoologique de thoiry a organisé pour la
première fois un 10 km dans ses allées
dans la réserve africaine et pourront
plus réaliser cette performance au plus
près des animaux reportage à suivre golf
une ryder cup étudiante baptisé jungers
cup est organisée cette semaine par
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines à plaisir et au golf de
jardy nous recevrons les organisateurs
sur ce plateau pour qu'il nous présente
ce rendez-vous fois l'actualité sportive
de la semaine c'est maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
on le répète chaque année la coupe de
france fait rêver tous les footballeurs
français cette compétition permet de
voir des scénarios rocambolesques que ce
week-end la magie opérer du côté de
montigny le bretonneux lésigny mon teint
qui évolue en deuxième division de
district ont réussi à renverser la
montagne choisy-le-roi une équipe de r2
une victoire au bout du suspense aux
tirs au but à un montage de à eghezée
déjà un tir au but qui marquera
l'histoire de montigny le bretonneux ce
dimanche 16 septembre 3ème tour de la
coupe de france les y monte 1 qui évolue
en d2 de district ont réussi à éliminer
choisy-le-roi une équipe qui évolue
pourtant trois divisions au dessus score
final 0 à 0 à 5 tirs au but à 3 ni par
content franchement j'ai pas trop les
mots parce que j'apprends à moi je les
ai fait cette façon là et a du coup à
très heureux très heureux si heureux
on a été solidaire et la satisfaction de
cette rencontre du côté ini montain
restera la défense ont-ils le bretonneux
qui avait encaissé quatre buts lors de
la première journée du championnat de d2
contre guyancourt a cette fois ci réussi
à résister face à l'armada offensive de
choisy le roi
très clairement on était on est en
dessous physiquement techniquement on
était en dessous mais on a été très
solidaire tactiquement les joueurs ont
fait preuve de rigueur donc voilà c'est
très positif
nous on fait un match de coupe de france
de france postaux dans les yeux prenant
0 0 ils ont vu les eaux turbulentes à
montigny le bretonneux jouera son
quatrième tour de la coupe de france le
30 septembre prochain l'adversaire lui
n'est pas encore connue n'importe quelle
équipe on vous continuez n'importe
laquelle franchement ya pas deux fois en
une heure non continuer une épopée écrit
un autre histoire à ne pas faire quelque
chose monti le bretonneux rêve déjà de
remplir le stade de la coupe pour ce
rendez vous et les supporters ne
demandent qu à l'enflammer
tour d'horizon à présent des principaux
résultats de ce troisième tour de coupe
de france versailles qui évolue en n3
n'a eu aucun mal à s'extirper du piège
tendu par le club d'ormesson l'équipe de
d2 score final 6 à 0 de son côté le
chesnay a failli réaliser l'exploit
contre bagneux mais s'incline 3 à 2
c'est terminé également pour bois d'arcy
bailly noisy deux équipes de d2 enfin l'
aventure continue pour vélizy qui
s'impose face à asnières et voisins le
bretonneux qui a réussi à sortir sèvres
1 à 0 rendez vous le dimanche 30
septembre pour le 4e tour de cette coupe
de france football encore le paris saint
germain a dévoilé officiellement jeudi
dernier les images de son futur son
entraînement à poissy situé à 25 minutes
du parc des princes la structure
permettra d'accueillir sur plus de 70 ha
les équipes de football et de handball
ainsi que l'école psg et les judokas du
club
au total il y aura dix sept terrains de
football un dojo un gymnase ainsi qu'un
stade de 5000 places
la structure permettra notamment
d'accueillir les équipes jeunes et
féminines du psg
coût total de l'opération 220 millions
d'euros entièrement financé par le club
la livraison est prévue pour l'été à
2021 handball féminin a menti le
bretonneux commence par une défaite dans
le championnat de nationale 2 lors de la
première journée les îles montaigne se
sont inclinés 33 à 24 face à ross hand
du 29 une défaite qui condamne pour
l'instant montigny le bretonneux à l'une
des dernières places du classement
toujours handball mais cette fois ci
chez les garçons pour sa première
apparition de la saison dans le
championnat de nationale 3 plaisir s'est
imposé de justesse sur le terrain de
montfermeil sur le score de 25 à 24 en
quête d'une montée cette saison les
pzero à se retrouve 4e après cette
victoire pour tenter de prolonger cette
bonne dynamique pelé
il tentera de remporter sa deuxième
victoire samedi soir prochain sur le
terrain de saint michel au sport du
baseball à présent les cougars de monti
le bretonneux ont réussi à se qualifier
pour les demi-finales des play-off de
première division lésigny montants sont
venus à bout des boucaniers de la
rochelle ce week-end à domicile
les cougars se sont imposés 7 à 4 dans
le premier match et 12 à 4 dans la
seconde partie
il reste donc en course pour la victoire
finale dans ce championnat on écoute
l'un des joueurs de l'équipe dit là le
maillot au micro de marylène et
iapichino voilà pendant ce temps nous on
est un peu au jour le jour où on passe
les étapes les unes par les unes après
les autres
mais ouais c'est sûr qu'on vise la
finale et on veut finir champion on est
capable on a réussi à secouer les
grosses écuries donc il n'y a pas de
raison
la demi-finale des cougars est
programmée le week-end prochain contre
montpellier l'une des équipes favorites
pour le titre de champion de france en
rugby a maintenant dans le championnat
de fédérale 2 plaisir n'y arrive
toujours pas les plaisirs aux achats
sont inclinés incliné pour la deuxième
fois en deux matches contre gennevillois
l'extérieur le score est très serré 26 à
23 avec ce résultat les évinois arrive à
obtenir le point de bonus défensif au
classement il pointe à la 9e place du
championnat sur 12 équipes engagées
un résultat à basket à présent le club
de lui et ses trappes n'a pas fait de
détail ce week-end en championnat de
nationale 3 les trappistes ont
pleinement réussi leur entrée en lice en
s'imposant regardez bien le score 112 à
53 sur leur terrain contre séguinière
saint louis basket une véritable
démonstration résultat qui permet
évidemment au trappistes de prendre déjà
la tête du championnat on ouvre une page
insolite à présent le parc zoologique de
thoiry proposé ce dimanche de courir à
10 km au milieu des zèbres au dessus des
tigres ou à côté des éléphants à
l'occasion de la twa rewind aweys
au total 1500 coureurs ont participé à
cette aventure des images de à marylène
et yapi kg le parc zoologique de thoiry
organisé ce dimanche 16 septembre l'une
des courses yvelinoise les plus
originales de l'année un 10 km dans les
allées du parc au milieu des animaux de
la savane pour cet événement plus de
1500 coureurs se sont inscrits plusieurs
semaines à l'avancé un énorme succès on
a été obligé d'arrêter les inscriptions
il ya déjà trois semaines parce qu'on
était arrivés à la limite de capacité
qu'on avait prévu 1500 dossards
ce qui fait de ce premier événement un
des premiers événements sportifs des
yvelines pour la première fois au niveau
sportif les coureurs l'ont pas eu le
temps de faire du tourisme à 100 %
malgré la proximité avec les animaux les
organisateurs avaient concocté un
parcours avec du rythme dans les espaces
verts c'était intéressant c'est comme un
petit trail plutôt qu'une course à pied
avec des dénivelés le passage sur la
passerelle
plutôt sympa on a un peu tous les
terrains du bitume et là on a une bonne
cote au château mais c'est hyper sympa
un moment il ya des marches aussi pour
passer au dessus des lions mais le
plaisir il est vraiment là puis on a un
super beau temps donc c'est vraiment
sympa vu le succès rencontré le parc
zoologique de thoiry devrait renouveler
l'expérience l'année prochaine
la course pourrait cette fois-ci
accueillir en plus un semi marathon et
de la marche nordique
on ouvre maintenant une large page golf
ce mercredi et jeudi une compétition
internationale étudiante sera organisée
dans les yvelines à mettra aux prises 14
jeunes français internationaux pour nous
parler de ce rendez vous baptisé jungers
cap nous recevons sur ce plateau l'un
des organisateurs pierre nieto de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines ainsi que l'un des
participants paul sa bague
bonsoir bonsoir alors comment avez-vous
eu l'idée de cette compétition en fait
lorsque nous avons appris que la
communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin et vélines avait la chasse
d'accueillir la ryder cup nous sommes
interrogés sur la façon dont
l'université qui est partie prenante et
parties entières du territoire pouvait
s'impliquer dans cet événement est donc
on a réfléchi autour de trois axes il ya
eu un premier un premier axe autour de
la thématique du annie golf et nous
avons collaboré avec la ville de
guyancourt sur une première journée qui
a été organisée au beurre nationale le
13 avril dans laquelle nous avons fait
intervenir des enseignants-chercheurs de
l'été de l'illisible ensuite nous avons
fait une deuxième partie au mois de juin
un symposium sport santé avec l'ufr des
sciences et de la santé dans lequel il
ya le golf bien sûr été impliqué et à
l'issue duquel la fédération française
de golf aux invités puisque c'était le
même jour que l'open de france
nous avons été invités au golf national
et ancré la troisième partie qui se
valaient plus festive autour des
étudiants c'était l'idée d'organiser une
compétition
dans un esprit de convivialité comme l'a
été créée la ryder cup une compétition à
laquelle les étudiants français
rencontrerait des étudiants étrangers
dans un esprit tout à fait conviviale et
sympathique donc au niveau des
participants ils seront quatorze ans je
disais précédemment
parmi eux paul paul pourquoi vous avez
décidé de participer à cette compétition
contacté en sommes j'étais content
acteurs d'un monde déjà par par pierre
j'ai eu la chance de qui nous propose
d'être de représenter l'équipe de l'ue
véhicule donc dedans a dit le capitaine
et puis après je trouve que c'est un c
c'est un événement qui participe un peu
à tout l'émulation qu'il ya autour du
golf grâce à la ryder cup en france et
je trouvais ça très sympa de pouvoir
participer à tout
toutes ces festivités autour du golf et
comment se sont fait les sélections
justement alors en fait des sélections
dans un premier temps j'ai contacté tous
mes collègues du directeur des sciences
de rennes des services universitaires
d'activités physiques et sportives des
universités parisiennes
d'un côté pour l'équipe française
ensuite pour la seleccion étrangères
j'ai contacté les différentes écoles
étrangères la british school l'american
school et puis j'ai contacté tous les
collègues aussi qui faisait du golfe un
régent parisien des écoles de région
parisienne de région parisienne louis et
ce n'était pas trop compliqué justement
talent les étudiants étrangers
ça a été je crois que vous avez quelques
soucis il ya eu quelques soucis parce
que il faut savoir que la ryder cup
départ situe le cob édition qui a été
créée par des britanniques et des
américains contre des américains pour
jouer contre les américaines dont moi
dans l'idée j'avais mon idée c'était si
vous voulez qu'il y ait quand même
quelques britanniques américains
représentaient donc j'ai contacté
l'américain disco qui malheureusement
n'a pas voulu donner suite pour
différentes raisons à cette compétition
et la british school a répondu
favorablement et donc on aura au moins
un étudiant en anglais qui sera
représenté dans cette compétition sinon
elle dit on se retrouve avec une équipe
française contre une sélection où il ya
bien sûr un britannique mais il ya aussi
des suédois
une japonaise luxembourgeois
voilà idée suisse et il fallait trouver
également des joueurs avec un bon niveau
alors si vous voulez au delà dans un
premier temps on voulait faire une
compétition avec une première partie
élite sur deux journées avec une
première partie élite sur le golf
d'isabella il deuxième partie plus tôt
2e série sur le golf de jardy mais comme
on n'a pas trouvé suffisamment de
candidats pour arriver à s'ils voulaient
organiser cette compétition et sur ce
premier modèle
j'ai été obligé de revoir la formule du
poème fait une compétition avec deux
équipes sur deux jours voilà ce qui fait
que si vous voulez les concurrents vont
se rencontrer en fera la moyenne sur les
deux jours avec comme spécificité car la
fin du premier jour sur le gold isabella
la fin du premier tournoi il y aura un
petit quizz sur l'histoire de la ryder
cup pour ça donne une petite spécificité
universitaire à cette compétition
ce quiz donc il y aura la compétition de
golf il y aurait également ce quiz
commentant comment vous trouvé l'idée
vaut paul d'associer les deux culture et
sport ben justement je trouve ça je
trouve ça bien puisque c'est quand même
c'est important de jouer au golf en
sachant un peu l'histoire du golf à
l'histoire de la ryder cup c'est quand
même un des événements les plus
médiatisés au monde
l'événement le plus médiatisé au moins
de l'ariège la coupe du monde de
football et les jeux olympiques
donc c'est quand un milliard de
téléspectateurs donc ouais c'est pas
rien c'est quelque chose de très
important pour pour le golfe et pour la
france
sachant qu'en plus le golf est pas
forcément le sport le plus représenté en
france donc
donc voilà c'est je trouve ça très bien
et justement où vous connaissez
l'histoire du golf parker ou vous pensez
vous en sortir au quiz bah j'espère
j'espère par coeur je sais pas peut-être
le raf que je révise un peu avant d'y
aller
est ce qu'il y aura des questions pièges
non pas du tout question piège il y aura
des questions non à c'est assez simple
mais
ce qu'il fallait ce qui était
intéressant on me posera des questions
c'était de balayer un peu l'histoire de
la ryder cup sur différentes époques
parce qu'il ya des grands noms de
l'histoire du golf qui marque qui ont
marqué dans ce sport et l'idée c'était
un peu de balayer toutes les époques
pour que tous les grands noms les plus
représentatifs du golf mondial ça soit
là quoi ça donne c'est dans ce qu'ils
avaient quelques questions un peu
anecdotique quand bien sûr paul au
niveau de la compétition comment vous
l'appréhendez vous voulez a remporté ses
objectifs c'est toujours l'objectif
après après l'objectif quand même
principal sera de passer un bon moment
et de de découvrir deux étudiants de
rencontrer plein de monde et de
patiemment même le niveau sera élevé sur
cette compétition il y aura un niveau
assez élevé passe et voir les futurs
tigerwoods peut-être sur cette
compétition tiger ou peut-être pas mais
il ya quand même déjà de très bonnes de
très bons joueurs alors on a été obligés
eux aussi d'essayer d'équilibrer pour
que c'est une scène sous les foyers il
fallait pas que ce retrait des
équipements d'un côté ou de l'autre donc
on a essayé de faire en sorte de choisir
des joueurs pour que les deux équipes
soient à peu près équilibrés dans le
premier niveau le mieux classé le
meilleur index sur un niveau de 4 mais
on avait aussi des possibilités avoir un
index négatif qu'on n'a pas pris part
sinon ils ont été trop déséquilibrée en
faveur de l'équipe française dans boulet
qui est quand même que ce soit surtout
fait dans un esprit convivial équilibrée
et surtout comme disait il au tout à
l'heure comme disait paul tout à l'heure
un esprit de partage de convivialité qui
fait la spécificité du sport
universitaire et l'idée aussi c'était de
mélanger les filles les garçons tout à
fait il fallait que sur scène comme
d'édition mixte et donc du coup il y
aura pratiquement autant de filles que
de garçons
mais qu'est-ce qu'on galère alors elle
est très intéressée par les questions en
gagne une superbe coupe qui sera offert
par le partenaire et du golfe et qui a
été fait par par hubert privés qui
participent notamment qui est sculpteur
qui participent de nombreux ouvrages
notamment avec collaborent pas mal le
bloc national dont ça c'est la coupe de
l'eiger ce club et ensuite j'ai de
nombreux partenaires notamment
on a beau le magazine on à wilson en a
le haras de jardy on a bien sûr isabella
on a le col c'est départementale des
yvelines et paris saclay bientôt pour
des cadeaux et voilà
christian paul et la serbie 10e est
entièrement gratuite et bien sûr
justement si on veut participer enfin
voir cette compétition quand ça se passe
ça riait gratuite pour tout le monde
elle est gratuite pour les joueurs est
gratuite pour les spectateurs il ya une
première partie qui se déroulera sur le
goff d'isabella mercredi de 13h à 18h à
18h30
on aura le quiz sur dix questions un
citoyen un petit cocktail et le
lendemain c'est les joueurs se
retrouveront sur le goal du haras de
jardy avec qui nous avons un partenaire
très privilégié avec l'université depuis
de nombreuses années et donc le gars le
haras de jardy qui organise ça de façon
très conviviale et à l'habitude va
ensuite organiser la deuxième partie et
qui sera suivie d'une espèce de petit
fayt d'un happy hour dans l'esprit
étudiants voilà dans l'esprit étudiants
merci à tous les deux d'être passé sur
ce plateau je rappelle que la
compétition baptisée junkers cup sera
organisée du 19 au 20 septembre golfe
isabella de plaisir au golf de jardy à
côté de versailles un reportage sur la
compétition sera à suivre cette semaine
sur tv 78 on continue à parler golfe et
de la ryder cup 2018 on connaît
désormais le dernier nom qui composera
l'équipe américaine le douzième homme
s'appelle le joueur s'appelle tony
finaux le joueur de 28 ans est l'un des
joueurs les plus réguliers de l'année il
a terminé deux fois dans le top 10 des
tournois il a également réussi à
terminer à la cinquième place du dernier
us open et 10e au masters est rejoint
dans les wild cards phil mickelson ainsi
que tiger woods deux figures du golf
national de ca dernière à zoner siens on
continue à parler de golf une conférence
débat sur l'héritage de la ryder cup
2018 en france était organisée jeudi
dernier à paris à la maison de la radio
la fédération française et les
organisateurs de la compétition
présentée à cette occasion les futures
retombées de la compétition sur la
population française selon eux la ryder
cup devéhat devrait permettre de booster
la pratique du golf en france on écoute
pascal grizot le président de la ryder
cup 2018 donc tout on pense qu'après
cette ryder cup
évidemment un plus grand nombre de
personnes auront pu
un premier contact avec le golf et on
espère que bien sûr ils vont se mettre à
jouer au golf mais comme j'ai eu
l'occasion de l'expliquer dans mon
intervention après la ryder cup en 2022
la fédération française de golf à gagner
la candidature pour accueillir les
championnats du monde amateurs pour les
garçons et pour les filles et en 2024 on
a les jeux olympiques donc je pense
vraiment pas que que le soufflé va
retomber après la ryder cup en clôture
cette page ryder cup par une
confirmation celle de la venue de
michael jordan six fois champion nba
lors de la compétition l'ancien à
basketteurs grand amateur de golf
viendra assister depuis les tribunes au
rendez vous parisien les spectateurs
pourront également vous pourront
également voir en action le surfeur
kelly slater multiple champion du monde
qui participera au match des célébrités
le 25 septembre prochain
enfin le ballon d'or portugais luis figo
ancien joueur du real madrid sera aussi
de la partie sur cette compétition
amicale
d'autres super stars n'ont pas encore
confirmé à leur présence après un
michael jordan on continue à parler
basket le cibi ciel et le corneille et
baskets campe los angeles va organiser
du 21 au 27 octobre un camp
d'entraînement à barcelone pour les
jeunes pour nous parler de ce rendez
vous nous avons le plaisir de recevoir
le fondateur du silice et les corneilles
ap
thakoon ainsi que charlotte guérin qui
participera au camp d'entraînement
bonsoir bonsoir
alors quand mayer pourquoi avez vous
décidé d'organiser cette compétition fin
c'est ce qu'ont l'entraînement est aussi
une compétition
oui mais aussi pour permettre un plus
grand nombre de gènes prioritairement
des yvelines de participer à des
entraînements de qualité de niveau
semi-professionnel pour qu'ils goûtent
un petit peu ce que c'est que le haut
niveau qu'on s'entraîne beaucoup pour
qu'il puisse pour progresser et revenir
ici pour montrer ce qu'ils ont appris
pour un accent là bas c'est vraiment
complet vraiment oui bien sûr bien sûr
entrée manquée à la fois qu'il va être à
la fois porté sur le physique mais qui
va être aussi forte portée sur le mental
qui leur permettra de progresser
vous avez beaucoup de choses on va avoir
quatre heures d'entraînement tous les
matins donc lever très tôt pour
les faire entrer dans un rythme de
sportifs de haut niveau quatre heures
d'entraînement de manière à ce qu'ils
puissent vraiment dans le fond pour que
le mental
mentalement ils puissent progresser sur
le mental on n'arrête pas être sportif
de haut niveau donc avec ce type
d'entraînement je sais qu'ils vont se
surpasser et devenir des meilleurs
sportifs sur l'autre gars hein ça sera
pas trop usant ceux comme entraînement
mentalement et physiquement
oui c'est c'est assez dur les lever mais
j'en avais déjà fait 1 à los angeles
et puis j'avais beaucoup aimé c'est pas
que basket au cc ya des visites de la
ville de barcelone par exemple et c'est
aussi un peu pour les vacances oui c'est
un peu pour les vacances etc une semaine
la toussaint c'est pas trop trop vite
sans donc je rappelle que vous êtes à
l'entente le chesnay versailles
est ce que ça vous aide après ensuite en
club ce type d'entraînement
oui c'est du perfectionnement individuel
alors que pendant les équipes en club on
fait plutôt du collectif et pour
atteindre un niveau plus haut il faut
surtout travailler sont individuelles ou
les shoots le tir le shoot la dribble
tout ce qui est perfectionnement
qu'est-ce que vous avez plus justement
améliorer votre avis c'est surtout le
dribble sur toulouse fc convaincant déjà
gg que fait le camp de los angeles
mais j'ai fait des entraînements le
samedi le dimanche avec le spécial est
d'accord et qu'est ce que vous avez pu
justement améliorer
oui donc le dribble je joue au poste 5
donc intérieure mais c'est très
intéressant de pouvoir travailler le
dribble en la montée de balle même si
c'est pas vraiment mon poste pour
pouvoir progresser dans un plus haut
niveau
quand est ce que vous sentez que
vraiment il gagne en maturité avec ces
stages énormément quand ils reviennent
dans leur club après énormément comme l
a dit c'est pas que que basket ya ce
côté éducatif sportif qui est important
où ils vont gagner en autonomie par avec
claude différents moyens que qu'on
utilise qui leur permet de revenir et de
comprendre en fait leur place au sein de
un groupe de savoir qu'est-ce qui
pourraient ils peuvent apporter de mieux
au groupe pour que le groupe soit
meilleur vous avez fait ces camps
d'entraînement à los angeles
pourquoi avoir choisi barcelone cette
fois ci très très bonne question
los angeles et une grosse réussite ça
plaît beaucoup
sauf que le problème tout le monde ne
peut pas venir à los angeles et je
voulais donner la chance à tout le monde
de pouvoir participer alors j'étais leur
délocaliser un petit peu le camp à
barcelone d'autant que l'espagne est
quand même ces vingt dernières années le
pays phare du basket en europe
voilà peut-être pas cette année n'ont
pas gagné le championnat d'europe mais
quand même depuis 15-20 ans ils ont
dominé que ce soit les clubs 4,5 club en
euroligue versement faim en espagne
donc je voyais pas d'autre endroit en
europe pour faire mais quand ça vous
attirer aussi peut-être vous de votre
côté que ce soit l'espagne plutôt que
los angeles encore j'ai envie de dire
basséen une nouvelle localisation le
sens du us j'avais déjà fait j'avais pas
vraiment j'avais pas vraiment envie de
le refaire mais l'espagne c'était je
prends espagnol à l'école même si
barcelone c'est spécial mais oui c'est
plus proche c'est moins contraignant
l'avion et c'est aussi une très belle
ville est-ce qu'il ya cinq ans des
places oulala ça va commencer à faire
juste oui il nous reste encore on va
dire une petite poignée de places mais
ça appartient à mon avion une semaine
et comment s'inscrire juste ans sur le
site internet officiel et point fr on a
tous qu'ils aient marqué rubrique
contact et réservation il ya un petit
imprimés à remplir et à nous renvoyer
tout simplement au niveau des tarifs
on n'est vraiment pas cher on est aux
attentes on a 1 990 euros pour le camp
payable en plusieurs fois pour permettre
le plus important c'est qu'ils puissent
venir c'est vraiment pas financier merci
à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau on
compte sur vous pour nous envoyer des
images de ce camp d'entraînement et des
photos de barcelone également avec on va
se maintenant notre page agenda on
commence cette page agenda par de la
course à pied ce dimanche matin le
dimanche prochain 25 mille coureurs
s'élanceront de paris pour rejoindre
versailles là qu'on se fêtera cette
année sa 41e édition le parcours ne
prend pas une ride en montage de jules
grandes villes la recette fonctionne
depuis 1976 les coureurs s'élanceront ce
dimanche 23 septembre à 10h depuis la
tour eiffel pour rejoindre le château de
versailles à l'occasion de la 41e
édition du paris versailles deux lieux
symboliques séparés par 16 km vous avez
des 6 premiers kilomètres de faux-plats
faut pas non plus aller trop vite et et
s'emballer et ensuite vous avez la
fameuse codé guère la cote du cimetière
qui est un peu mais méconnue mais qui
tient à qui tient son rang qui tient son
rang et puis ensuite vous avez le faux
plat sur l'avenue de paris qui pour moi
l'une des plus grandes difficultés
puisque vous avez 1 km 500 de faux plats
et
une grande largeur de chaussée comme
tous les ans 25 mille coureurs dont 90%
de la région parisienne sont une
nouvelle fois attendus sur l'événement
les inscriptions sont complètes depuis
le mois de juin
pour beaucoup de gens c'est une course
d'entrée de deux jeunes coureurs si
j'ose dire et à tout le monde court un
petit peu puis un jour un peu plus puis
on a des copains qui courra avec soin et
puis qui eux sont des coureurs un peu
plus chevronnés inscrire leurs amis sur
cette course là parce que c'est ce qui
est le maître c'est quand même relaté
montcourt petite nouveauté cette année
les organisateurs ont créé une
application on pourra voir les temps de
passage des coureurs sur trois secteurs
elle sera disponible à partir du 20
septembre tout semble prêt pour
accueillir la plus grande course à pied
des yvelines il n'y aura pas que paris
versailles ce week-end il y aura
également du rugby fia avec le début du
championnat honneur en versailles qui
s'est renforcé cet été pour monter en
fédérale 3 se déplacera sur le terrain
de montesson et versailles et seront
évidemment favoris de cette rencontre le
derby vinoy de cette poule i n'est
programmée ce dimanche à 15 heures au
parc des sports de montesson si vous
voulez assister au match l'entrée est
libre a toujours d'un championnat de
division honneur mais cette fois ci dans
la poule 2 le saint quentin en yvelines
rugby il se rendra ce dimanche à 15
heures sur le teint de melun combs
senart pour débuter son championnat
un déplacement compliqué pour les saint
quentinois qui ont flirté avec la zone
de relégation toute la saison dernière
cette année est les bleus et verts ont
de plus grandes ambitions ils viseront
une place dans la première moitié du
classement
si la fin de cette émission merci
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour une nouvelle émission pas
dit s'il a passé une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tb 78
[Musique]